[Music]
good things that come in tubes
toothpaste
paint
mayonnaise
fish eggs
prawn cheese
[Music]
mackerel and tomato in a tube and for
those last few you can thank sweden
thanks a lot
in sweden it's not uncommon to get your
daily sustenance from a
tube it is something very swedish but i
think many swedes don't really realize
that it's something unique
my name is carla marie paredes i am
originally from the philippines but i am
based in sweden i've been in sweden
since 2012.
carla is fascinated by sweden's food in
tubes so much so that she actually wrote
her master's thesis on it
i wrote 65 pages
of yeah
[Music]
so some of these products you can use on
a sandwich
these are caviar and the spreadable
cheese and pates
you have another category which is more
for dressings and condiments mayonnaise
or like hamburger dressing and then you
also have purees like tomato puree which
you can use for cooking
[Music]
but for the most popular way to eat food
from a tube you need your bread cracker
or as the swedes call it can i burn
perfect now you need a topping what
about the king of food tubes callus
caviar
it's made from salted or smoked cod row
or what about a cheese in a tube bacon
cheese shrimp and crayfish cheese blue
cheese with pear
yeah there's a lot
you would definitely also find this you
know in denmark in norway and finland in
germany but i'm not sure if it's as big
in those countries as here in sweden
[Music]
they all look delicious but what i don't
understand is why the tubes
i would say maybe it's a culture of
practicality and functionality it's very
convenient it's very clean you know it's
easy to dose the product
all swedes kind of have their own way of
emptying it as much as they can
there are some like contraptions that
you can use to like fold it somehow so
that you put it here and then you just
roll it and try to squeeze everything
out of it
okay so have the swedes one you over i'm
not swedish so this was something that
it was like acquired taste in a way
i do have like bacon cheese but it's not
really something that i eat often it's
more like it's in my fridge this is the
only flavor of spreadable cheese that i
actually really eat
you know what i think if anything can
get me into food tubes it's probably
bacon
thanks carla and happy eating
[Music]
hey everybody my name is drew bibi and
i'm here in my terrible home studio that
i've made during quarantine and i wanted
to tell you about our new podcast called
great big story it's got more surprising
and delightful stories just like this
one so head over to apple podcast to
spotify wherever you get your favorite
podcasts and download great big story